so what I asked you guys on Twitter what
my video should be for this week
darkside war at 2 was the clear winner
by leaps and bounds and so as we get
into the beginning of act 2 what we do
is pick up with the events immediately
following the conclusion of act 1
something I want to pay special
attention to is that the one shots
following the completion of act 1 and
the beginning of act 2 aren't really a
necessity for those of you who were
following my videos on the first part of
the story you will notice that I stopped
at the Batman one-shot the reason for
this is due to the fact that the one
shots are flash Superman Green Lantern
Shazam and Lex Luthor are best covered
after the release of the first story of
act 2 with that in mind where this video
will undoubtedly leave some questions
what it will also do is set the stage
for the varying one shots by sending
different characters off in their own
situations which will be covered under
their individual stories having said
that as we get into this we join the
combined forces of Jessica Cruz Wonder
Woman mr. miracle
cyborg Shazam and the flash following
the death of Darkseid at the hands of
the anti-monitor as a bit of a refresher
as a conclusion of act 1 as the
anti-monitor was previously a being
named mobius who look to explore the
antimatter universe upon discovering its
origin mobius unwittingly released the
anti-life equation and aspect of the DC
universe allowing its wielder to
dominate the will of others because the
anti-life equation had transformed
mobius into the anti-monitor mobius was
imbued with its power and during his
battle with dark side force Barry Allen
to merge with the black racer one of
deaths aspects who killed Darkseid while
being controlled by mobius while
Superman and Lex Luthor battled the
various forces of Darkseid during their
time trapped in apocalypse because a
planet did not have a Yellow Sun Clark
found himself becoming consistently
weaker during which time Lex threw him
into one of apocalypse of solar pits
with Superman emerging having been
corrupted by its energies and possessing
a modest improvement to his powers while
simultaneously losing his desire to hold
back now picking up with the current
moment because Clark has taken on a much
darker persona rather than escaping
apocalypse alongside Lex
instead he chooses to leave him to his
fate on the planet now this moment is
essentially Jeff Jones giving us an
explanation of what all has happened to
with a final issue of darkside War Act
one ended with Superman stating that he
was tired of fighting on behalf of
people who didn't deserve it and had
intended to make the decision for
himself as to who was entitled to live
or die in this instance the true change
of Superman hits home and the idea that
his previous role of acting as a hero
and role model has not been cast aside
to be replaced by his corrupted form who
for all intents and purposes has been
driven mad by the pits of Apokolips now
transitioning to Batman alongside Hal
Jordan this portion of the story
establishes how things have changed
following the death of Darkseid and its
ramifications what we're told is that
because anti-monitor had killed Darkseid
a byproduct of this act is that mobius
is now undergoing the process of ridding
himself of the anti-life equation now in
truth we will get a better understanding
of what Batman is referring to later in
this video the conversation between Hal
Jordan and Batman also leads into
Bruce's one-shot comic by revealing that
with Darkseid dead and anti-monitor
temporarily out of the picture the
ability for Bruce to know all things
that have and are happening by way of
the Mobius chair will allow him to
function as the Batman that Gotham
deserves what Bruce also reveals to us
is that because Darkseid kept his ilk in
order using a combination of fear and
power without Darkseid to control
apocalypse or its forces the parademons
are essentially roaming throughout the
universe now again like Batman and
Superman the situation of the parademons
presents an issue that requires a coming
together of the Green Lantern Corps and
sets the stage for Hal Jordans one-shot
comic which will cover his actions in
dealing with a pair of demons as well as
a Green Lantern Corps and the guardians
of the universe themselves and so
picking up with Lex Luthor what I want
to do here is sidetrack for a second and
talk about the nature of the planet
apocalypse in DC Comics apocalypse is
usually depicted in a limited capacity
with only glimpses provided in differing
stories as a result these glimpses had
given way to the idea that the planet is
effectively destitute barren and only
inhabited by differing races from across
the multiverse who are in the process of
being converted into para demons in
truth apocalypse is actually inhabited
by a wide array of different groups with
a society functioning in a hierarchical
fashion the majority of the populace and
its lowest class are referred to as
lolis who were considered to be the scum
of the planet
with no sense of self-worth or value
following the low leaves are parademons
who serve as the police of apocalypse
and are usually engineered from lowly
themselves or from conquered foes above
the parademons are the female Furies
something to note is that the name
female Furies is actually a misnomer
since there are male members of the
group but the Furies essentially operate
as Darkseid's personal guard and are led
by granny goodness a former loli who
worked her way through the ranks of dark
side forces and to her current position
as well as canto a human who would kill
dark sides former top assassin and took
its place now the individual seen here
encountering Lex are actually a new
creation by Geoff Johns called The
Forgotten people who are led by a woman
named R Dora and was actually
interesting about this is that those who
have an affinity for older comics will
actually recognize the door as a
character from the Silver Age who
debuted in Superman number 167 and
hailed from a world called lexer where
its citizens reviewed Lex Luthor as a
hero while she was killed in 1983 as
part of the lead-up to crisis on
Infinite Earths John's inclusion of her
character into this story is designed to
reflect her original appearance and that
according to the blind profits of her
people when Darkseid dies a human would
walk the ashes and change everything now
where this plot thread will find his
continuation in Lex Luthor one-shot
weather story does is shift its focus
back to earth with Jessica Cruz flash
Shazam cyborg and Wonder Woman regarding
this particular bit the speech of Barry
Allen actually provides some valuable
insight into his character and how he
views life after emerging with a black
racer what he tells us is that because a
concept of death exists by extension the
value of life is enhanced and that the
heroes of Earth function to ensure the
protection of that very life as a result
if death didn't exist the positive led
to the who they are may have been vastly
different giving way to an infinite
number of possibilities on who they
might have become however before the
flash can finish he vanishes from the
area during which time we shift our
focus to Billy Batson where John's
doesn't give us a lot to go on here
during this instance
Billy's met with a barrage of voices
which seemed to emanate from the
pantheon of gods who provide him with
his powers where this will also play out
in the Sam one shot and see a new host
of God to play
those Solomon Hercules Atlas Zeus
Achilles and mercury when he disappears
from the landscape with Wonder Woman
proposing that the group split in half
searching for Shazam and flash their
attempt is thwarted by the arrival of
Kalibak the son of Darkseid who had lost
his eyes while battling Grail at this
point we travel back to Lex Luthor who's
still being held captive by the
Forgotten people during which time we
learn that their intention is to capture
the Omega effective Darkseid harness it
and channel it into Lex to focus on this
for a second the Omega effect is
somewhat enigmatic in that it's both a
plot device to explain to our site's
power but is also a physical source of
energy on the whole the general
consensus among readers as far as I've
been able to tell is that the Omega
effect is the opposite of the source
which exists as the source of all things
within the DC multiverse where this is a
little ambiguous because the Omega
effect serves as a source of Darkseid's
power following his death the Omega
effect began traveling back to
apocalypse to this end with the
intention of the Forgotten people is to
harness that power through Lex Luthor
once this happens the story shifts its
focus to following up with Grail while
simultaneously establishing what Luthor
has become what we're told is that after
the death of Darkseid Mobius I cocoon
himself into a kind of energy sphere and
begun the process of returning to a more
humanoid form now how much you will
change is something we won't actually
discover in this video instead what
John's is doing here is setting the
stage for what comes next with Mobius
essentially continuing on with vast
abilities and the concept of the
anti-monitor existing as a plot device
reboots being thrown out the window in
addition to this we also learn that Lex
Luthor has successfully harnessed the
power of the Omega Effect transforming
him into the god of apocalypse and
taking Darkseid's place from here we're
going to be a little bit dangerous and
we're actually going to jump over the
one shots and straight to the second
part of act 2 now if you're interested
in seeing the 1 shots feel free to post
a comment below and let me know but like
most any trilogy or ongoing series this
portion of the story continues the idea
of information while including a little
bit of action opening up with a
monologue from Wonder Woman what this
does is provide a story that's designed
to juxtapose the new gods of Batman
Superman fly
Shazaam Green Lantern and Lex with a
story of I know and Dionysus where the
story as told by Wonder Woman is a
little limited in Greek mythology there
existed a woman named Sam L the daughter
of Bo Asian hero Cadmus and his wife
Harmonia and sister of I know in the
Greek stories Cemil had been visited and
was impregnated by Zeus an affair that
was discovered when he revisited Cemil
under the guise of an old woman planting
seeds of doubt in the mind of Simone
Hera drove Sanel to call upon Zeus
directly to prove his godhood and
establish that he was the father
however because death always befell
those who looked upon a Greek god who
was undisguised Sam L died on the spot
was Zeus taking the unborn child unto
his own now where the story begins to
splinter off into differing variations
is when Zeus allows the unborn child to
gestate within his own leg after which
things play out in a multitude of
different ways within this story Geoff
Johns has gone with the most popular
theme of Dionysus being handed over to I
know to be raised away from Hera's wrath
however once Herod learned that the
child still lived she drove I know to
madness who jumped off a cliff with
Dionysus in her arms but was saved at
the last minute by Zeus who grand
veteran mortality is gods of the sea so
they could never be touched by Hera now
the reason for John's including this
tale in the opening of this issue is it
during Homer's epic poem Odyssey
Odysseus had escaped the wrath of
Poseidon where Odysseus would have died
to the torrent of the sea and its
violence he was saved after being
provided a veil by I know which carried
him to shore saving his life and
allowing the rest of the story to
continue what John's is essentially
doing here is using the idea of one
calamity to establish that from the
destruction brought by its existence
there can be new life and rebirth but
not without trials and tribulations of
its own meaning that the new gods of
batman/superman and so on have to come
to grips with their new powers cast off
the corrupted natures and return to
their role as heroes to this end with
Kalibak and his forces arriving to seek
the revenge for the death of Darkseid we
pick up with Jessica Cruz who continues
her inner struggle with full food while
simultaneously fighting Callum back now
if you're interested in learning more
about Jessica I have it
under character in my previous videos on
darkside war but while she focuses her
efforts on Kalibak and lishchyna we also
shift our focus to mr. miracle
however because scot-free is an escape
artist with no physical powers his
battle against Kanto is more akin to
dodging attacks rather than being
offensive in addition to this as we
discuss in my previous videos on
darkside war the conflict between Kanto
and scott-free is long lived in that
Scott head routinely escaped cantos
attempts to return to apocalypse under
the service of darkseid as a result the
battle between the two is less about
revenge over dark sides death and more
about Kanto and to me to finally kill
the quarry who was escaped him so often
however in the midst of their fight big
Barda makes her presence known on the
battlefield now in truth Barda is a
character that we haven't really talked
about before and to be honest she's a
character
I'm not wildly familiar with I did talk
to some of you on periscope and the
general consensus was that Barda had
appeared as part of the lead up to
Darkseid war during earth two worlds in
but disappeared after that and didn't
reappear until this story however the
main focus on her in the context of the
events as they're unfolding now is that
because she had turned against Darkseid
she was considered an eternal enemy of
the Furies in Kanto who looked at kill
her for her treachery to this end
because she still harbors a love for
scott-free she uses her sword to kill
Kanto after which she turns our
attention to Kalibak Steppenwolf and the
rest of their forces something that's
also interesting here is that like the
parademons despite the fact that
Darkseid is dead they continue to swear
their allegiance to him even if only in
memory now to be honest I would go as
far as to say that the allegiance hell
is more out of fear that if Darkseid
returned and found his forces had
deserted him he would likely hunt them
down and kill them all but regardless of
their motivations the fact remains that
the Scott should granny goodness
discover that he and Barda are still in
league with one another granny is almost
certain to find them and killed him on
the other hand for Barda the death of
Darkseid signals an opportunity for them
to essentially start their lives over
free from his control
indeed this particular point is made by
Barda when she speaks directly to
lishchyna presenting a ceasefire stating
that if the fury stay away then Barda
and Scott free will stay away however
because the hatred of lishchyna and the
Furies transcends their loyalty
darkside and is rooted in their feeling
of being betrayed the offer is declined
with Lucchino claiming that they will
continue to hunt down Barda and Scott
free until their deaths from here we
jump back to Marina and Grail as a to
stand before the cocoon of Mobius what
we're told is that while he undergoes
his metamorphosis into what he was prior
to being possessed by the anti-life
equation because he is in such a
vulnerable state he has employed shadow
demons to protect him by warding off or
killing anyone who strays too close now
to focus on this for a second we've
never really delved into the idea of the
shadow demons in the realm of DC Comics
but these are essentially the weaponers
accord who function as the mortal
enemies of the guardians of the universe
and live within the antimatter universe
but because the anti-monitor was
all-powerful during his time there the
weaponers were transformed into the
shadow demons sometimes willingly and
sometimes unwillingly but existed as
soldiers for mobius in addition to this
as we transition back to Wonder Woman
enter forces we also learn that because
they still don't know why anti-monitor
arrived on earth in the first place
their initial goal should be to seek out
the crime syndicate of america who
battled anti-monitor
and were forced to abandon their earthly
universe in the conflict however the
problem faced by the league is that
Argus the Amanda Waller led government
agency holding the remnants of the crime
syndicate have classified them as level
0 inmates now for those of you who had
seen the first season of Heroes or
coming from Marvel Comics a level 0
classification is essentially a level 5
classification from heroes and the raft
and Marvel Comics as a result were
Wonder Woman and the others discussed
their inability to communicate with Hal
Jordan or Batman with Scott free able to
enter or exit any building due to both
his ability to pick locks as well as his
mother box teleporter his services are
offered to the league as a means to
enter Bellerive prison question the
crime syndicate and escape without
getting caught
from here the story shifts its focus to
a conversation between Steve Trevor and
Wonder Woman now to be honest this isn't
really essential to the overall Darkseid
arc but it does give us some insight
into how Steve views the end of the
relationship and Wonder Woman's
seemingly pursuit of Superman what Diana
tells us is that of all the conflicts
the league has been in since his
formation in the new 52 they have yet to
encounter a situation quite like this
another league itself is fractured with
most of its summer possessing heightened
godlike powers furthermore Diana
considers the current predicament with
the anti-monitor to be an Amazonian
affair and that Grail is the product of
dark side and morena black who is an
Amazonian and it brought this entire
situation down on their heads in an
effort to force a conflict between
anti-monitor and dark side to this end
diana sees this as a situation that
needs to be handled in-house however for
steve his feelings come in the form that
like the early days of superman when he
wouldn't date Lois Lane due to the
dangerous life that comes with having
powers Steve believes that the
relationship between himself and Wonder
Woman ended due to her desire to find
someone who could keep up with her
dangerous life where Wonder Woman
doesn't really deny this the implication
from what John's is telling us is that
she's torn between her affections for
Steve and that he had helped her
understand how to function among normal
society and Superman who is able to keep
up with her physically however before
the two of them were able to continue
their conversation any further Superman
Returns ceasing Trevor from behind at
this point Jobs gives us a kind of
monologue from Grail while establishing
a series of events and sequence and that
with the Mobius chair
Batman remains obsessed with finding out
who the Joker is Mobius continues his
metamorphosis within his cocoon Wonder
Woman engages Superman in battle to
protect Steve and the rest of the league
alongside Scott and Barda arrive in
Belle Reve prison and so his dark side
war Act two comes to a close with Hal
Jordan returning to gotham following the
events of the one-shot comic we learn
that the entire reason for why Grail had
allied herself with anti-monitor in the
first place was that she had either
known or suspected that with the
anti-life equation mobius was guaranteed
to be the victor meaning that once he
began his metamorphosis the anti-life
equation would be cast off allowing for
Grail to take possession of it making
her the goddess of anti-life with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end if you guys have any
questions feel free to post them down in
the comment section I'll answer them if
I can or some of you guys happen to see
the questions and you can answer them
better than I can feel free to post up a
response and I will catch you guys later
peace